let's say a screenwriter is working on a
based on a true story type screenplay
and it's either based on a real person
or a real historical event so if this
real person let's say is still living
does the screenwriter need release forms
from this real person what about that
bidding on this is a question we get
asked all the time and um it I guess the
first the first answer to that is
legally no you do not need to get those
rights there are a whole host of good
reasons to go out and get what we call
life rights or even a release from that
person but legally we all have a right
under the First Amendment to tell a
truthful story so if that story is
truthful which if you don't have the
rights that person we have to make extra
special care to make sure that it is you
don't need any rights in that individual
if you think about books how many books
there are probably every president of
the United States the president doesn't
necessarily authorize every single one
of those books he authorizes one that
has the best picture of him on the front
but the other ones are written because
we will have a first of them right to
write those stories based on information
that's in the public and so the legal
answer is no and then why get them and
there's a whole lot of good reasons one
is to reduce liability you know just
because the law is on your side doesn't
mean people won't get upset about
something or think that they should have
gotten their right to quired on so a
liability issue a delivery issue you
know if you plan on delivering this to a
big studio they like to see those types
of agreements in place again because of
the risk and also you might want to have
access to that person they might have
journals and pictures and access to
other people that you want to interview
or conduct research with and they can
provide that access so it's there's a
lot of good reasons to get life rights
but legally you don't need to so let's
suppose though I change the name and
some of the characteristics would that
make it safer for me or again still no
do the journalism to do a
do the research and create an accurate
portrayal you're allowed some dramatic
flexibility but we have to work with a
screenwriter on that and I gave you in
another answer the example of welcome to
New York where it was about Dominique
strauss-kahn there are two arguments
between mr. and mrs. Khan that are
totally made up nobody was there except
them and we weren't able to talk to them
but the scenes were reasonable
inferences from everything we did know
so there's some flexibility even on that
but they so often people think oh I'll
change the name and that'll fix it the
issue is is the film of or concerning a
certain person and very often I act by
I've been five my favorite example is we
had a film in about Michael Jackson's
alleged proclivity for little boys and
the the there was one chauffeur in the
film throughout the film and i said to
the filmmaker is this man still alive oh
no we changed his name and we and i said
but it's the same show for oh yes
Michael Jackson always used the same
chauffeur when he had boys in the car I
said so what good is it to change the
name well we we changed the ethnicity
and we changed his name yeah but there
was only one driver that's the guy you
could make them a Martian and it would
be this man so you have to be very
careful about the notion of all make a
few changes and it'll be okay I don't
know where that came from
as long as the person is still
recognizable so recognizable so you know
you you see films all the time and they
call a person I don't know jack instead
of John like wow look at that now you'll
never know it was really John and yet if
a person does then legally you can still
be on the hook
you